bit of a tough day today magnus how
would you summarize it
yeah let's put it mildly um i have to
say uh
he uh played
played well uh put me under pressure
from
move one and i had zero to give today
just nothing
how is it to actually try to perform in
a sport like chess when you're not
feeling 100 physically
i mean
i think like one day one game is always
fine but
day after day it takes takes a toll
and
last three days i
i'm feeling like
a bit healthier
but
i have no energy uh in my body
whatsoever i still should play
should play better uh but on a day like
today when my opponent plays
really well um
[Music]
then it's not so easy um
and uh
yeah today's performance was just not
nearly good enough
in the third game you choose to leave
the queens on the board is that in a
hope to actually win this with a black
and get a direct win or are you not
thinking about the tournament standings
yeah i was dumb uh i mean i i
i
i i mean i i saw the
standings were a little bit more
favorable to me
after
except my own game of course after game
two than game one but i still thought
realistically i had to win both games uh
but uh i mean there's a right way to try
and do that and there's a wrong way um
to do it
and certainly i didn't do the the right
way but
i i also
if i
change the queens i'm still still worse
so
i think i'm
my position is even worse when after
what i after what i do then then if i'd
exchange but
regardless i don't
i think the damage was kind of already
done
thank you for taking the time on this
thank you